there another two brits missing we had
one die yesterday and one is still
missing what's being done to get these
people back so the foreign office uh
obviously is very working very closely
uh with those in ukraine uh both uh to
make sure that you know the
identification is correct
and indeed to work with local
authorities and to support uh families
here you know as we've uh set out right
from the beginning
we don't want british nationals to go
and
fight but there are many many ways in
which so many people and i think the the
heartfelt uh genuinely heartfelt anxiety
and appalledness that uh putin has
illegally invaded and is now continuing
uh to bombard those areas where he had
stepped away is something that quite
rightly horrifies the british public and
there are many ways that we can all
support through humanitarian through uh
opening our homes through supporting
through uh the financial channels but we
don't want people to go and fight but
obviously the front office is doing all
it can uh to support and identify these
two people i mean we're saying that now
we don't want people to go and fire
that's not quite what the foreign
secretary said at the beginning of this
war is that she said that she would
support those who wanted to go and fight
for what she saw as a just cause in
ukraine she was wrong to say that wasn't
she at the time so she she continued to
explain after that that uh we do not
want british nationals to go at the time
obviously the advice was to not go
to grendel that remains the travel
advice for obvious reasons because it's
a war zone and we want to make sure
that people can show their support their
solidarity for ukrainians and for uh the
battle that those extraordinary people
are doing to fight for the freedom of
their country through all those other
ways
and uh it is extraordinary how generous
the british people are being both with
their own their own homes with their
money uh with their time to support the
ukrainian families and just a thought
then on that british support for
ukrainians coming here that scheme is
still not working as well as it should
is it at the moment there are still
massive problems in bureaucracy in
ukrainians arriving
so uh the process uh has been slow and
lord harrington uh is working literally
uh day in day out night and day with his
team to make it flow um i think we've
had nearly 75 000 visas
now granted i've had two families
arrived last weekend into my
constituency who've been welcomed it's
been so touching welcomed uh by the
whole community uh i mean in a sense of
warmth and affection and there are more
from their own community uh who will be
coming but we want to make sure that all
those uh who are coming will be going to
a safe place so local councillors have
been asked to obviously go and uh check
the uh homes being offered we don't want
anyone to be found in a difficult
environment where they might be put
under kind of any kind of stresses so we
want to make sure that it's rigorous and
that visa system is working it has been
cumbersome but lord harrington is
absolutely focused on it and anyone who
is uh watching who is you know keen to
be generous with their home please do be
in touch with your p if you feel the
process uh is getting stuck somewhere i
mean cumbersome is one way to put it is
this a problem with like civil servants
not being in the office
uh no this is a process because it was
set out as i say uh whilst we are uh you
know one of the most generous countries
in well wanting to welcome people in uh
and the home sector has set this out a
number of times we want to make sure
that we are both uh bringing people who
are who will be very traumatized and
very vulnerable into safe places so the
councils have been asked to do a number
of checks to make sure that the homes
are indeed at once where they can save
and also uh making sure
that these
refugee routes are not going to be
abused by those who wish to come into
the uk and do our citizens harm
absolutely right well look let's leave
ukraine there for a moment we must talk
about what's happening in westminster at
the moment your colleague suella
braveman described some a minority of
your colleagues as animals for the way
they behave in parliament do you agree
so i think all of us uh as uh women in
parliament have uh been subjected to uh
inappropriate language uh to you know
wandering hands uh as well my granny
used to call it uh it doesn't it doesn't
change the vast majority of
the men i work with are delightful
they're you know committed
parliamentarians they're passionate
about the causes they fight but there
are a few for whom uh you know too much
drink or indeed a sort of you know a
view that somehow being elected makes
them you know god's gift to women that
they can suddenly uh please themselves
that is never okay that kind of behavior
disrespect for women and indeed uh some
of the uh you know the younger women who
are not parliamentarians who are part of
our you know parliamentary family that
is never okay it's never okay anywhere
it's not okay in westminster either
and you know we have had a number of uh
you know ways to help uh women now share
their anxiety the experiences they've
had uh following on from the metoo
campaign a few years ago we have now
started to make
frameworks that ensure that women can
speak up but it's still i think
not as good as fundamentally if you're a
bloke keep your hands in your pockets
and behave as you would if you had your
daughter in there you'd hope that they
would but you know you set up that
scheme five years ago yeah after me too
it's not doing what it should be doing
is it this is still happening so no it
is going to be the people can uh refer
and indeed yeah but it's not deterring
the men from behaving in the way that
there is an interesting question this is
what what is the what is the relevance
deterrent that would ensure uh that
those that minority and it is a minority
of men who think it's okay to behave
inappropriately would feel the pain and
using the whip
uh so well you know a number of times
that has been used and i i see that um
liam burn uh was uh
you know formally chastised this week
for bullying another entirely
inappropriate uh way of behaving in the
workplace or anywhere i mean these are
these are just you know ways of behaving
that are not acceptable and those of us
who have uh you know public roles or
responsibility and uh we are indeed you
know should be
demonstrating what good behavior and
leadership looks like need to make sure
that we are all doing that so i am very
firm i'm very comfortable calling out
anybody who thinks that their wandering
hands are okay and i have done it a
number of times over the years so people
do that to me and i will always
encourage uh women to be to feel
empowered to say so publicly but that's
difficult for those uh who are younger
and where that power difference is very
well so we continue to champion them i
absolutely i hope there is a place for
them to come forward and hope they feel
confident that they can do that but it's
more than one hands is this is a guy who
perhaps was watching porn more than once
in the house of commons i mean that is
disgraceful behavior he should be sucked
well i mean it's it's just completely
unacceptable uh to be uh you know well a
why's he got the time uh b uh why does
he think that's okay what are you doing
the prior to your own home uh as a as an
adult it is a different issue um so why
is he still got the whip and why does
that so i haven't had a chance actually
uh to speak to because i've been
out about but i think
the issue is there and the
grievances committee uh system is now in
place and i know that the speaker is uh
very focused on getting to this issue
and i haven't i haven't been able to
talk to anyone this week too but it is
completely unacceptable
you know that the chief whip knows this
person's name you we i'm sure that
people senior members in the party know
who he is he was reported by two of your
colleagues he's still got the whip we
don't know who he is
why is that happening why is the party
being so slow to take action against
this person who was watching pornography
in the house of commons so as i say i
haven't had a chance to talk to chief
whip and i know that we are uh
the uh
ladies in question who apparently uh saw
this completely completely inappropriate
activity uh have been uh encouraged to
use the formal system in the house
commons to be able to report it and i
hope very much that they will or indeed
have i don't know um and that the system
will uh demonstrate if that was the case
exactly uh what the punishment should be
for that sort of inappropriate behaviour
i mean you said you haven't spoken to
people about this and that's perfectly
fine but is your party doing enough do
you think should one will be done
i'm very very confident the chief whip
i'm a a great fan of christine harris's
uh will follow both working with
parliament and parliamentary processes
uh to make sure that that is both robust
and provides the support to the uh women
in question and that he will take a
decision that is appropriate uh when
it's right i mean you mentioned the
behavior at the beginning you mentioned
this idea of wandering hand it's much
more than that it's much more serious in
many instances let's be clear about that
um but you also mentioned the drink
culture boozing at westminster now
people watching this will be amazed that
parliamentarians can go and have a drink
and then perhaps go back to work go and
have a debate speak with other
colleagues
do you think it's time to ban alcohol in
the house of commons because it seems to
be a real problem and enabling people to
behave in terrible ways so again for
most people that isn't the case we do
have when we have long sittings uh uh
when you know when a monday you know in
my world starts at 8am with meetings and
if we're not voting until 10 it's a long
day so i will you know that i am fed by
the house of commons uh several times
during the day we have canteens we can
go to and in the evening if there is a
pause there's nothing wrong with you
know having having a drink with your
colleagues a chance to catch up and
discuss you know matters of the day it's
those who uh you know abuse and you know
find the drinking culture too strong
that is not okay and that's something
that has improved a great deal uh when
you talk to those who've been in
parliament for you know much longer than
the vast majority of have the culture
was a much heavier drinking culture than
it was but that sense of responsible
drinking which we advocate and i would
advocate to my kids and to anyone else
is something that we want to see yes
throughout the place and that's what we
need to work on at every level
responsible drink is one thing but you
know we don't allow people to drink and
drive because most of us won't drink and
drive but some people do so that's why
we ban it now people in parliament are
drinking and behaving badly
shouldn't we bamboos in parliament
um i you know people can go around to
the red line up the road and go for have
a drink if they're waiting that's not
quite the same it's on site isn't it and
i think probably heavily subsidized as
well um not particularly no uh but
actually the reality is uh that there's
nothing wrong i think in in the course
of anything or at the end at the end of
a working day we may vote at seven on a
tuesday for instance at the end of the
working day you might go
around the corner to a pub with your
mates after work as indeed you know many
people do from the office then you're
going home you're not going back to work
where this stuff so there is the
challenge that it is with parliament is
that we are in this very unusual
location the key message and i would say
to colleagues and i have many times uh
said to people is you know there's
nothing wrong with having you know a
drink with colleagues a chance to
discuss issues responsible drinking has
to be the way forwards and we know we
continue to try and prove that
absolutely okay international trade
secretary deal has been signed with
switzerland um we're able to do that
deal but we still can't get brexit done
what's going on there
so uh we have obviously our uh train
cooperation agreement with the eu and
that is uh all signed and sealed and we
continue now to work in the new
environment uh which is uh the uk as an
independent trading nation uh and we are
also now able to build those trade deals
as a result of being out of the u with
nations across the world so we're
working on a trade deal with india which
will be a huge opportunity for british
businesses uh with uh the cptp which is
a great uh indo-pacific uh group of
eight a market of eight billion pounds
uh we've just signed a deal with
australia and with new zealand and a
digital economy agreement with singapore
a really exciting part the uk is leading
the world in helping business to go
digital which strips away cost both for
the business but also for the consumer
so we're working across the world now a
freedom that's been given to us since
brexit to be able to really provide as
many tools as businesses uh need and are
asking us for so that we can get much
better opportunities for our consumers i
mean that's all great but we still can't
sort out the border arrangements for
northern ireland why is that taking so
long and why have we decided now to push
it off until the end of next year so as
uh the uh brexit opportunities ministers
set out uh we want to make sure that
those inward flows coming into the uk
continue to be smooth the discussions
continue they're led by uh the fcdo uh
on how to try and uh ensure that those
trade diversion issues that we've seen
in northern ireland is there a cost
issue
uh no it's it's a it's for consumers
it's a floatage um
so what the the idea of uh you know
opening borders and ensuring that trade
flow is that trade is there so northern
ireland businesses have been seeing
trade diversion it's a concern that they
have so the fcdo continues to have
discussions with eu to find the right
ways uh to try and reduce those
problems and to make sure that trade can
flow as well as it could make things
more expensive for consumers the the
situation that's there on the board so
we want to continue to make sure that we
uh both have those flows that are
unencumbered and that it works really
well for businesses and of course at the
end of the line is the consumer so uh
more friction uh can bring more costs so
uh we continue to work with the eu to
find the best solutions for that okay i
think we finally got there at the end it
may be a bit more expensive but we're
not saying the brexit is going to make
things more expensive of course i'm
marie schubelium international secretary
for trey thank you very much for being
with us thank you